[Music]
tap water for the average American it's
as dull as well dishwater but even
though you can't see it there's a lot
going on when we dive deeper to see
what's inside
like sulfates which determine hardness
and no we're not talking ice cubes in
this case hardness refers to water with
a high mineral content like the stuff
you might drink at a spa though it can
be hard on plumbing leading to the
formation of limescale and the
heartbreak of soap scum
that's why hard water is typically
softened with ion exchange resins and
polymers or you can just wait for
nature's own hydraulic cycle to soften
and purify h2o the old fashioned way
through evaporation condensation and
eventually precipitation hard or soft
though tap water is typically an
invisible cocktail of whatever
impurities it's picked up along the way
to your faucet for example the Big Apple
boasts about the quality of its drinking
water from upstate reservoirs but not so
much about the potentially unhealthy
levels of lead they can leach into the
liquid as it travels through the pipes
of the city's ancient plumbing system
and purification agents are often as bad
as the impurities that they treat like
chloramines which can damage red blood
cells and I doses or trihalomethanes
which are meant to kill microorganisms
but may damage your liver and DNA don't
worry though
assuming there's no fracking nearby your
tap waters probably safe and non
flammable especially if you catch the
impurities in the pores of the activated
carbon or ion exchange resin inside most
commercial point of use filters and
since healthy hydration is the key to
long life we'll definitely drink to that
enjoy other episodes of what's inside by
subscribing to the Wired Channel